Johnson appeared on something called the
rich role podcast this week where he
offered his theories about life and
human immortality and so Jen zero is a
group of multiethnic multinational
people who rise up and they say we are
willing to courageously step into the
future and we're willing to divorce or
open to divorce from ourselves all human
Norms all human Customs all human
thought and we're willing to say we're
wide open open wide about everything
absolute Blank Slate divorcing yourself
from Human Norms from traditions and
customs and severing yourself from the
past to the extent that such a thing is
even possible is a recipe for crushing
misery Despair and decay